Santiago Peña venció en las
presidenciales de Paraguay y mantuvo al
partido Colorado en el poder con el
42,74% de los votos superó por mucho a
su contrincante Efraín alegre líder de
una amplia coalición de Centro izquierda
la concertación nacional quien logró el
27,48% de los apoyos sobre lo que le
viene al país después de esta elección
conversamos con José Duarte penayo
sociólogo y doctor en filosofía
paraguayo señor penayo muchas gracias
por estar con nosotros hoy en France 24
con Peña continúa el poder casi
ininterrumpido del partido Colorado de
más de siete décadas porque se quedó
Alegre en el camino y con él la
posibilidad de alternancia política en
estas elecciones las votaciones por el
opositor fueron significativamente
inferiores a lo que se esperaba
muy buenos días Rodrigo Muchas gracias
por la invitación y a toda la audiencia
de Juan veinticuatro las elecciones
fueron históricas para el partido
Colorado ha hecho una de las diferencias
o la diferencia más amplia en todo el
proceso democrático que en el Paraguay
Inicia con la caída de stroner desde
1992 las razones
del fracaso de la concertación son
varias y en gran medida tienen que ver
con la figura de Efraín alegre que en su
tercer intento no ha logrado unir a las
diferentes
candidaturas que pugnaron y dividieron
el voto opositor por un lado pero debe
decirse también que uno de los elementos
que explica estos resultados de la
impecable campaña que ha llevado el
partido Colorado y la gran es donde ha
ratificado su fuerza como un partido
nacional de gran penetración territorial
y de una cultura democracia interna muy
fuerte de la que carecen las demás los
hemos partidos políticos y fuerzas
políticas del sistema paraguayo
yo quería preguntarle ahora qué se
espera de la agenda política del señor
Peña porque cada vez hay más pedidos a
favor de que se respeten más los
derechos humanos en el país
Especialmente los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos
la agenda la campaña del candidato
Santiago Peña ha sido una campaña
orientada en la necesidad de recuperar
la senda de crecimiento económico la
generación de empleo del Paraguay ha
pasado por un momento difícil en estos
años de vida sucesivas crisis como la
pandemia la más importante quizás pero
también
hubo problemas climáticos como la sequía
esos han sido los problemas centrales
Los ejes de esta campaña y sobre esos
ejes el candidato Peña tuvo el acierto
de proponer un eslogan que ha penetrado
en la gente ya que ha tenido una gran
eficacia vamos a estar mejor pues bajo
esa Consigna pues bajo esa promesa y
esperanza de una recuperación de la
Hacienda del crecimiento
que ha triunfado debe recordarse que el
partido Colorado es uno de los pocos
partidos quizás el único en América
Latina que ha logrado retener el poder
luego de la pandemia todos los
oficialismos en América Latina han sido
derrotados
y en gran medida esto también tiene que
ver con la resiliencia de la economía de
la sociedad paraguaya y con las acciones
de este gobierno que se está yendo que
fueron pueden ser discutidas o
criticables en muchos aspectos pero
lograron estabilizar el país generar un
contexto de paz social y de tranquilidad
en el que se dieron estos estos comicios
sin discusión alguna y con una victoria
muy contundente del partido Colorado tu
consulta Rodrigo es un tema que no ha
sido tema de campaña ni siquiera de los
sectores progresistas que en este país
deberían En todo caso militares esas
causas no ha sido tema nunca ha sido
reivindicación del expresidente Fernando
Lugo y su fuerza política hoy
prácticamente desaparecida al mapa
político por lo que la centralidad de
esa cuestión no forma parte de la agenda
política del Paraguay me refiero no en
especial a los Derechos Humanos que es
un tema transversal sino al de las
minorías sí entiendo yo quería
preguntarle por lo que usted esta amplia
Victoria tan importante para el partido
Colorado Y es que Santiago Peña llegaba
también en reemplazo del ex mandatario
Horacio cartes que había sido sancionado
por corrupción por Estados Unidos podría
esta corrupción dentro del partido
Colorado ser un problema de
gobernabilidad para Peña durante este
periodo de cinco años Bueno una pequeña
corrección Santiago Peña sucede al
presidente Mario abdo Benítez Perdón
es importante este dato no No
necesariamente quiero hacer una
corrección sino por qué menciono esto
porque la gran eficacia del partido
Colorado en todo el proceso democrático
consiste en su capacidad de ser en todos
los gobiernos fuerza gubernamental y
fuerza disidente y esta capacidad que
tiene el partido Colorado por ser un
partido nacional tan amplio tan grande
de tanta penetración territorial y hace
que ante cada nueva contienda electoral
de una facción del pluralismo que
presenta Se presenta como la renovación
y que promete ser el cambio interno en
todo este proceso salvo en una elección
esta dinámica ha sido exitosa y ha
logrado disputar y convencer a amplios
sectores de la sociedad paraguaya que la
posibilidad de cambio siempre se
encuentra el interior del partido
Colorado entonces Santiago Peña fue la
propuesta de cambio de renovación el
luego del gobierno de Mario abdo Benítez
él tuvo un primer intento como candidato
a presidente al fin del gobierno de
Horacio cartes en el que perdió las
internas coloradas las primarias y en
este segundo intento sí tuvo éxito y
llegó al poder con con una con la
diferencia que ya sabemos en una de las
victorias más importantes que tuvo el
partido Colorado pero recalco que es
esta dinámica que tiene el partido
Colorado de gobierno y oposición la que
le da su fuerza y la que de alguna de
algún modo expresa la la fuerte
democracia interna y la gimnasia
electoral a la que está acostumbrado el
partido Colorado y de y al que no están
los otros partidos políticos esa fue una
gran ventaja en estas contiendas sumado
a otros cambios en el sistema electoral
como el desbloqueo de listas del voto
preferencial que dieron un empujón muy
fuerte a diferentes candidaturas locales
que sustentaron la victoria de Peña
José Duarte penayo Muchas gracias por
estar con nosotros hoy en France 24 y
por este excelente repaso de lo que ha
sido la campaña y las votaciones Muchas
gracias Rodrigo a toda la audiencia de
cuatro Saludos muy especial desde
Paraguay un saludo de nuevo y muchas
gracias a nuestra audiencia les invito a
que sigan con nosotros Porque volvemos
en apenas unos segundos aquí con directo
América
[Música]